14 year old Chet walks into a room  no one knows anything about me  all they know is that I'm Tom hanks's  son yeah there's going to be immediate  assumptions okay  the Assumption right  the number one assumption  that people make  is number one I must live the life of  like Richie Rich spoiled Rich Kids  spoiled rich brat  number two the the assumption is I think  that I'm better than everyone in the  room  that I feel that I that I truly think  that I'm superior to every single person  in that room you're a 14 year old kid  with a Target on his back before you  even step in the room before I even step  in the room and the truth was  those both of those things couldn't have  been farther from the truth I wasn't  spoiled I was blessed I was privileged  right but I wasn't spoiled there's a big  difference